So now we have the wireframes
implemented for both screens.
But what does it look like on the tablet?
Well, unfortunately, when we
take the phone UI
and stretch it out on a tablet,
it doesn't look that great.
There's a lot of empty white space here.
We could better take advantage
of this screen real estate
by showing more useful information.
For example, why do these details
need to be a tap away
when they could just as easily
fit on this screen?
And, furthermore, if the user
wants to look through
the full list of forecasts,
their eyes must go like this,
which is an unpleasant
reading experience.
If we want the user to read some content,
we should keep the width narrower,
so that they can scan it quickly.
These considerations are part
of responsive design.
Responsive design means
designing your app
by keeping in mind
that it'll be used across
a range of different device screen sizes.
How do we do that,
and what does it mean to build
for larger screen devices like tablet's.
Well, I can show you some examples of how
apps adapt using multi-pane layouts.
In the Android Design Guide,
there's a section on multi-pane layouts.
One technique is to combine
multiple views together.
For example, in the People app,
you have the contact list
and the contact card
for additional details.
On the tablet, we can
put them side by side.
This is also known
as the MasterDetailFlow.
This is the master list
and this is the detail pane.
In the settings app,
we have another example.
The column width adjust
based on the available screen width.
In the calendar app, we have panels,
and they stack vertically
in the portrait orientation,
but horizontally
in the landscape orientation.
There also a couple of other examples
that you can look through as well.
If you want more information
on designing for tablet's
or responsive design in general,
you can check out the links below
for more details.
In this course, we're learning
how to build up the phone UI first,
and then the tablet UI.
But in reality, when we're designing it,
we thought about responsive design
from day one.
When you're building your own app,
it'sbad practice to just completely
design and build your phone app
and then start to brainstorm
about the tablet UI.
That's because the tablet UI often
has an impact on the phone design,
as well as the architectural
decisions made here.